Sind wir in der Notaufnahme oder im Praxis?
Visible, ja.
In der Notaufnahme.
Hallo Guten Tag. Ich bin hier zustande geassisten ersten Tätig.
Mit ihnen würde ich gerne dieses Aufnahmegespräch führen, bevor wir über ihre aktuelle Beschwerden sprechen möchte.
Ich habe ein paar Allgemeine Fragen.
Bin Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, gerne Frau Doktor. Wie ist denn Ihre Name, bitte?
Okay. Wie heißen Sie?
Ne, wie heißen Sie denn Frau Doktor?
Ah, ich schuldige. Mein Name ist Kapagan.
Kapagan?
Gan.
Kapagan.
Eigentlich Kapagan.
Ge ist leicht. Ge ist auch türkisch.
Okay Frau Kapagan, Frau Doktor Kapagan. Guten Tag oder Guten Abend. Hallo.
Hallo. Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Franz.
Franz.
Füllen Sie bitte Ihre Nachname büchtern?
Mein Nachname ist Franz Friedrich Richard. Anton Nordpol Zeppelin.
Anton Nordpol Zeppelin.
Franz, Ihre Vorname?
Vorname ist, das habe ich gesagt, Roman.
Herr Roman Franz.
Wie heißen Sie, Herr Franz?
Ich bin 56 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ich bin geboren am 17.06. 1969.
1969? Machen Sie eine Fehler?
Olavilis.
Herr Franz, wie viel wiegen Sie?
Oh, ich habe zu viel Gewicht. Ich wiege im Moment ca. 123 kg.
123?
123.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin ein bisschen kleiner geworden, ungefähr 1,70 m.
1,70 m.
Okay.
Okay Herr Franz, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Frau Doktor Kapagan, ich habe seit ca. 4 Wochen zunehmende Luftnoten
und es pfeift immer beim Ein- und Ausatmen.
Es wird nicht mehr so viel wiegen.
Das macht mir jetzt Angst.
Deswegen bin ich bei Ihnen.
Ich war bei meinem Hausarzt, aber der kommt nicht weiter.
Und jetzt wollte ich hier von Ihnen mal untersucht werden.
Wann gehen Sie beim Hausarzt?
Ich war letzte Woche beim Hausarzt.
Haben Sie momentan Atemnot?
In Ruhe habe ich keine Atemnot.
Wenn ich aber etwas laufe und so weiter,
dann ist das keine richtige Atemnot.
Aber ich höre, wie es pfeift.
Das belastet mich.
Dann fällt mir auch das Atmen etwas schwer.
Haben Sie momentan Stress?
Nein, ich bin in Rente.
Ich habe kein Stress.
Aber wie gesagt, das ist jetzt erst seit 4 Wochen.
Das hat angefangen mit etwas Husten, ein bisschen Halsschmerzen,
aber ich habe es nicht mehr.
Haben Sie eine Gefühle?
Ja, das war circa 37, 39, 38.
Aber das war nur für einen Tag.
Jetzt habe ich kein Fieber.
Es war so 2-3 Tage, habe ich mich etwas schlapp gefühlt.
Ich hatte auch meine 3. Booster-Impfung 2 Tage vorher.
Ich dachte, das kommt von der Impfung.
Aber danach ging es wieder besser.
Aber jetzt seit 3 Wochen ungefähr,
ist es so, dass ich im Prinzip schwer Luft bekomme.
Es pfeift die ganze Zeit.
Wussten Sie?
Manchmal, nicht immer.
Der kommt der Auswurf?
Eigentlich nicht, es ist eher trocken.
Aber manchmal kommt ein Auswurf, der ist aber eher hähn.
Kommt der Auswurf nach dem Ausstieg?
Ach so, da habe ich eigentlich keinen.
Da habe ich sehr Held, denn da kommt schon mal,
der ist manchmal gelb, aber ist danach eigentlich relativ klar.
Aber Sie bruschen mehr?
Nein, so einen Druck habe ich nicht.
Ich kenne das, ich habe schon mal einen Herzinfarkt.
Ich habe es auch nicht.
Ich kenne das, ich habe schon mal einen Herzinfarkt,
vor 10 Jahren gehabt.
Da habe ich Druck auf der Brust.
Ich bin auch immer regelmäßig beim Kardiologen in Behandlung.
Ich war erst vor einem halben Jahr beim Kardiologen.
Ich sagte, es ist alles in Ordnung.
Das war damals anders.
Jetzt habe ich keinen Druck auf der Brust.
Engegeben?
Nein, auch kein Engegebühle,
aber ich bekomme einfach nur schlechter Luft.
Trätten Sie, Sie haben schon gesagt,
Ihre Beschwerden sind beim Belastung aufgetreten.
Ja, bei Belastung werden Sie mehr, das stimmt ja.
Okay.
Sind Ihre Beschwerden
wenn sie im Bett liegen,
verschlimmert?
Teiljahr, wenn ich mich hinlege,
dann muss ich mehr husten.
Und da wird es ein bisschen schwerer mit der Luft.
Das stimmt ja.
Im Sitzen fühle ich mich besser, das ist wichtig.
Schlafen Sie viel mehr
Kinder, Kinder, Kinder, Kinder,
Kinder, Kinder, Kinder,
viel mehr Kissen.
Oder?
Ich merke, wenn ich zwei Kissen habe,
dann ist das ich besser schlafe, als wenn ich lachen.
Das ist richtig.
Sind Ihre Beschwerden dauerhaft oder schubweise?
Also im Moment.
Im Moment war es weniger,
und jetzt ist es mehr geworden.
Ich habe seit zwei, drei Tagen dauerhaft
Anhalt, diese Luftnot.
Haben Sie früher,
als ich den Herz infrage hatte,
da war dieser Druck.
Seitdem hatte ich keine Probleme, das ist jetzt neu.
Diese Art der Luftnot.
Haben Sie bei der Beschwerden
auflösen, für Ihre Atemnot?
Nein, ist immer da.
Aus der Belastung? Nein.
Sie haben keine Fieber,
aber sie fühlen sich
fiebergefühlt.
Das war ganz am Anfang,
jetzt habe ich kein Fieber, nein.
Ist Ihnen übelst? Nein.
Haben Sie erbrochen? Nein, habe ich auch.
Haben Sie Herzrausen oder Herzklopfen? Nein, das habe ich nicht.
Alles so weit gut vom Herzen.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit ungewollt ab oder zu genommen?
Das wäre schön, wenn ich abnehmen würde.
Aber ich habe leider nicht abgenommen.
Nein, immer noch gleich.
Der Appetit ist auch gut.
Trinken Sie genug Wasser oder mehr Wasser?
Ja, ich trinke schon ausreichend Wasser am Tag.
Haben Sie in der Schwindelik? Nein, das habe ich nicht.
Können Sie gut ein- und durchschlafen?
Mit dem Schlafen habe ich kein Problem.
Das ist jetzt natürlich ein bisschen schwieriger.
Wenn ich mich hinlege, dann ist es schwieriger.
Das Einschlafen ist ganz gut,
aber ich werde in der Nacht immer wieder wach.
Ich merke, dass ich mich aufsetzen muss,
damit ich besser Luft bekomme.
Sie brauchen tiefer.
Was erlassst du?
Was erlassst du? Nein, das klappt ganz gut.
Da habe ich kein Problem.
Haben Sie Probleme mit Verstöpfung oder Durchwahl?
Nein, das klappt wunderbar.
Da habe ich keine Probleme.
Das ist ein bisschen schwer.
Ich möchte für Sie und ich zusammenfassen.
Sie klagen über Atemnot.
Und gefällt seit vier Wochen zu nehmen.
Atemnot haben Sie.
Und Sie fühlen sich sehr schlapp.
Vor zwei Wochen haben Sie dritte Impfung von Poster geimpft.
Vor vier Wochen ungefähr.
Sie haben keine Brustschmerksten.
Sie wussten sehr leicht.
Und trockene Hüsten haben Sie keinen Auswurf.
Sie haben keine Auswurf.
Kein Auswurf.
Bei Belastung ist Ihr Atemnot verschlimmert.
Herr Franz, trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ab und zu mal bei Gelegenheit, aber nicht so.
Brauchen Sie?
Nein, das mache ich nicht mehr.
Nicht mehr oder nicht?
Im Moment brauche ich nicht.
Ich habe vor 30 Jahren mal geraucht, aber seitdem nicht mehr.
Okay.
Probieren Sie Drogen?
Nein.
Sie haben schon 3, 10 Punkte geimpft.
Sie haben Grundimpfungen geimpft.
Ja, da habe ich alles komplett.
Mein Haus hat es verfolgt.
Ich habe gegen Tetanus, gegen Zecken.
Die habe ich alle.
Okay.
Leiden Sie an außerhalb der Erdinfarkten?
Ja, ich habe noch einen leichten Diabetes.
Der Arzt meint, ich brauche keine Medikation im Moment.
Ich habe keine Medikation im Moment.
Ich brauche keine Medikation im Moment.
Ansonsten habe ich auch ein bisschen Gift.
Da nehme ich etwas dagegen.
Ein hohen Blutdruck, das hatte ich ja gesagt, ist bekannt.
Ich habe hohe Fettwerte.
Da nehme ich auch Medikamente.
Für den Blutdruck habe ich amnodipin und ramiprin.
10 mg?
5 mg.
Tagelich einmal.
Dann habe ich erst 100 mg.
Ramipril auch 5 mg?
Ja, ich habe 5 mg.
Ich habe 5 mg.
Tagelich einmal.
Ich habe erst 100 mg.
Und für das Kolesterol nehme ich rosovastatin.
Ich habe 5 mg.
Sie haben schon gesagt,
Sie waren beim Arzt.
Arzt geht.
Herr Franz,
leben Sie allein?
Nein, meine Familie, ich bin verheiratet.
Ich habe eine kleine Tochter.
Und denen geht es gut.
Sie sind glücklicherweise nicht krank.
Sind Sie ehepaar?
Haben Sie ehepaar?
Nein, ich bin verheiratet.
Sie sind beide gesund.
Ihre Tochter und ihre Frau.
Ja, ja, die sind beide gesund.
Haben Sie ähnliche Beschwerden?
Nein, nein.
Die haben keine Beschwerden.
Diejenigen geht es gut.
Leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Ja, sie sind leider verstorben.
Woran sind Ihre Eltern gestorben?
Mein Vater hatte einen Schlaganfall.
Und meine Mutter hatte eine Blutvergüftung.
Sie hatte eine Gallenblasenentzündung.
Und ist sehr spät erkannt worden.
Und konnte dann nicht mehr operiert werden.
Und dann war es nicht mehr so.
Sie ist an einer Sepsis verstorben.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie krönliche Alkranen?
Wie Krebs?
Ich habe eine entfernte Referente an seine Kusine.
Die hatten Hirntumor.
Sie wurde operiert, aber ich weiß nicht, was das für ein Tumor das ist.
Ansonsten sind alle, soweit ich weiß, relativ gesund.
Ich bin Verränder.
Herr Franz, ich habe für mich alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Gestellt?
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Vielen Dank, Frau Doktor, dass Sie sich so viel Zeit genommen haben.
Ich habe eine gute Frage.
Ich möchte eigentlich nur wissen, was es ist.
Können Sie mir etwas verschreiben?
Womit das besser wird, können wir auch sagen, was es vielleicht ist.
Momentan sollen Sie hierbleiben.
Und jetzt untersuchen Sie es.
Jetzt führe ich körperliche Untersuchungen durch.
Und dann ein paar Blutbild- und Röntgenaufnahme möchten.
Sie möchten noch weitere Untersuchungen durchführen, wie eine Blutabnahme und eine Röntgenuntersuchung.
Ich möchte mit meinem Chef Arzt oder Oberarzt über ihre Beschwerden sprechen.
Machen Sie auch ein EKG Frau Doktor? Ich habe ein bisschen Angst um meinen Herz.
Ja, ich weiß. Jetzt schreibe ich EKG.
Und mit Puls-Ox-Metre messe ich ihre Sauerstoff-Sättigung.
Was ist eine Sauerstoff-Sättigung, Frau Doktor?
Wir messen in ihrer Blutgefäß den Gehalt in Halte Sauerstoff.
Die Höhe des Sauerstoffs oder den Gehalt des Sauerstoffs.
Vielen Dank.
Jetzt haben Sie den Patienten untersucht.
Sie hören aufs Herz.
Herztöne sind rein, sind rhythmisch und sind gleichmäßig.
Sie hören auf die Lunge.
Die Lunge hat ausgeprägte Spastik, hat leichte Rasselgeräusche.
Aber die Lunge ist beidseits bis in die Spitzen belüftet.
Der Patient ist vom Abdomen her unauffällig.
Keine Druckschmerzen, keine Auffälligkeiten.
Der restliche Körper und Untersuchung ist auch unauffällig.
Neurologisch zeigt, der Patient keine Defizite.
Die Vitalparameter sind in Ordnung.
Sie machen eine Übergabe an den Oberarzt.
Danach sprechen wir über die Diagnosen.
Ich brauche 3 Minuten.
Sie haben nur 30 Sekunden.
Sie können sich überlegen.
Vielleicht haben die anderen Kollegen in der Zwischenzeit Fragen.
Möchte jemand noch zu dem Patient oder Frau Doktor etwas fragen?
Alle sind zufrieden.
Waren Sie in einer mit vielen Populationen zusammengegeben?
Ja, wir sind eine große Familie.
Wir gehören zu dem Volksstamm der Sintiroma.
Früher hat man auch Zigeuna gesagt.
Wir haben immer viele Menschen um uns.
Wir haben eine große Familie und eine große Verwandtschaft.
Daher haben wir immer viel Kontakt mit vielen Menschen.
Was war eine Partie?
Feiern.
Wir hatten in den letzten 4 Wochen eine.
Wir haben uns nur zu Weihnachten.
Wir hatten auch zu Weihnachten getroffen.
Aber da war ich etwas krank.
Wir waren ca. 20 Leute.
Sie waren eigentlich nicht gesund.
Auch im Nachhinein hat keiner eine Problematik.
Außer mir.
Sie können auch gerne Fragen stellen.
Bitte auf Deutsch.
Was meinen Sie mit Unfall?
Mit Auto?
Nein, ich hatte kein Unfall.
Die Frau Doktor überlegt sich.
Bitte Frau Doktor.
Ich mache jetzt ein bisschen Druck.
Ich habe eine kleine Frage.
Was ist das für Sie?
Ich habe einen neuen Patient aufgenommen.
Ein 56-jähriger Patient.
Herr Roman Franz.
Er stellte sich bei uns.
Seit 4 Wochen.
Ich habe ihn mit einem neuen Patient aufgenommen.
Er stellte sich bei uns.
Seit 5 Wochen.
ic
Er stellte sich bei uns.
Ich habe die Schlappe von der Schlappe von der Sierke.
Bechverden sein bei Belastung, Schlima geworden und er würde trockenen Husten.
Was er würde? Er würde trockenen Husten. Trocken Husten?
Er hatte keine Auswurf.
Für vier Wochen wurde er mit der 3. Corona-Impfstoff geimpft.
Ist geimpft?
Es gibt keine Auslöser.
Früher hat er keine ähnliche Beschwerden aufgetreten.
Die vegetative Anamnese sind unauffällig.
Er leidet an Geist, Bluthochdruck und Hypercholesterinämie.
Für ca. 10 Jahre hat er den Schlima-Impfstoff erfunden.
Er hatte die Arteriellenhypertonie,
und hat 5 mg. am Lodipin,
und hat 5 mg. am Hypercholesterinämie.
Wie heisst es Medikament?
Cholesterin.
Rosovastatin.
Er ist ein Rauker, und trinkt gelegentlich Alkohol.
Er trinkt gelegentlich Alkohol.
Er drogt und wurde geneint.
Perneint.
Er trinkt gelegentlich Alkohol.
Sehr gut, Frau Doktor.
Was Gefehlte hat, war vielleicht die Frage nach den Unterschenkelödemen,
wenn Sie schon an Herzinsuffizienz denken.
Welchen Laborwert würden Sie gerne kontrollieren
und wie schwer ein Herzinsuffizienz wiegt?
Welche Laborparameter gibt Ihnen da gute Hinweise?
BNP.
Das Nt pro BNP, das Natriodioretische, bla bla bla.
BNP ist gut, sehr gut.
Eigentlich ist es ein guter Parameter,
denn wenn dieser Wert niedrig ist,
dann kann man relativ sicher sagen,
dass es keine Herzinsuffizienz ist.
Wenn der Wert sehr hoch ist, sehr hoch bedeutet 1000 oder 2000,
dann hat er eine Herzinsuffizienz.
Dann muss man das Herz sich genau angucken,
woher das kommt mit der Herzinsuffizienz.
Ist es eine KHK, ist es eine Rhythmusstörung,
ist es Vorhofflemmen, ist es eine Myokanditis oder was auch immer.
Dementsprechend muss man ihm dann natürlich medikamentös behandeln.
Ich habe eine BNP,
ist BNP ausschließende Parameter?
Ausschließend nicht unbedingt,
aber das ist ein guter Wert, um zu sagen,
ob es eine Herzinsuffizienz ist oder nicht.
Wenn Sie ein normales BNP haben,
dann können Sie eigentlich sicher sagen,
das ist keine Herzinsuffizienz.
Wenn jemand aber ein sehr, sehr hohes BNP hat,
dann kann man eigentlich auch relativ sicher sagen,
das ist eine Herzinsuffizienz.
Aber das ist nicht nur der eine Wert.
Das hilft einem, die Diagnose zu stellen,
aber man macht es nicht nur an diesem Wert aus.
Es gibt natürlich andere,
es gibt auch einige neurologische Erkrankungen,
es gibt andere Infektionen,
die können auch BNP etwas erhöhen.
Sehr gut, Frau Doktor Karagan, war das Karagan?
Kapagan.
Ja, durchher war es so einfach,
aber jetzt neue Namen.
Dann müssen Sie Ihre Namen wieder annehmen.
Sehr gut, wunderbar.
Herzlichen Dank, jetzt haben wir insgesamt 50 Minuten.